beetle a bell of the ball after putting
on a pair of japanese rhinoceros beetle
earrings and burn rubber on your desk
driving a wireless sports car mouse
because it's episode 54 of loot
the tiny tesla musical tesla coil kit
fittingly allows you to build a tesla
coil that can play music by heating the
air and creating pressure waves we hear
as sound you can order spare parts if it
ever breaks down and it comes with a usb
connection so you'll be listening to
midi pirates of the caribbean in no time
time to battle some helicopters with the
sky terminators rc helicopter set a pair
of rc copters that shoot lasers at each
other they have shields to help protect
their weak spot but if the copter gets
hit five times it goes down if you'd
rather build vehicles then shoot them
check out the air power racer kit a diy
toy that teaches you about using air as
an alternate source of power the car
uses compressed air to propel itself and
moves surprisingly fast fill this
volleyball court with air on the water
the aqua aquaglide super volley floating
volleyball court is an extension for the
super [ __ ] 35 which means that yes
billy floating trampoline volleyball
just became a sport oh my god my name is
billy sport these handmade pumps once
you decide to make it back to dry land
zombie peep show sells custom shoes
clothing and accessories ranging from
alice in wonderland high heels to jason
from friday the 13th put water safety
first with the kinji inflatable
flotation device designed to be worn on
your wrist like a watch the device is
unobtrusive and easy to activate simply
pull the lever and a bag will inflate
and stay buoyant for up to 48 hours and
it comes with an attached whistle to
signal for help help yourself to some
easy slushies with zoku freeze the inner
core pour a chilled beverage into the
cup stir and then watch as it freezes
right before your very eyes handy horse
handy horse of course it's a handy
but can you drink from the handy horse
nay you'll need the magical unicorn
champagne horn to fill your mystical
beverage holding needs if you need a
game that's powered by magnets try the
hovercraft levitating challenge as you
stacking blocks on a hovering platform
adjust how stable the hover platform is
and it plays out like a futuristic game
of reverse jenga reverse your
expectations for what candy should taste
like with these stinger pops made with
the three hottest peppers in the world
so pick a pepper and pray you don't end
up needing first aid
i have snow okay i'm seriously
light-headed for those that require cute
and cuddly aid falling asleep look no
further than the sleep aid puppy a
stuffed animal that when activated lets
out a gentle pulse for 20 minutes it's
designed to help you synchronize your
breathing and heartbeat so you can calm
yourself when stressed or fall asleep
when tired the beard bundle will
guarantee never tire of your beard
products the service sends a variety of
oils soaps and balms and you can choose
from three different levels of beard
care minimalist lumber sexual and
majestic take in the majesty of mars
from your bedroom with bars in my room a
nightlight that depicts the red planet
in great detail and has points of light
to mark where the mars rovers have
landed it also comes with a pack of mars
lander cards that give you information
on the different mars missions mars then
pile more planet stuff on your plate
with planet plates just keep uranus in
the cupboard if you're having a dinner
party after dinner sneak out with the b9
urban stealth bike a bicycle inspired by
the f-117 nighthawk aircraft the single
speed bike comes with an atomic 22
security system which renders the bike
useless to anyone without the proper key
and its carbon belt drive is quieter
than a chain doesn't need to be greased
and lasts longer you can't ride a bike
without some safety equipment though so
be sure to bring along a chainmail
keychain for protection which you can
attach to your constructor diy slr
camera a kit that lets you build your
own slr camera all while learning about
how single lens reflex cameras actually
work now that you've got a camera light
the scene with the pixel stick an led
light painting wand that you can use to
create amazing time-lapse photos put the
image or design you want on an sd card
pop it into the wand and wave it in
front of a camera set to long exposure
but remember if you get in my way i've
got one thing to say don't stop meow
sorry and as always thanks for watching
you